Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhudassa
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
So, I just want to carry on this week with the world-conquering monarch.
Just to finish it off, because we're starting at the top with government.
And if you remember from the last talk, we said that the
this monarch, the wheel-turning monarch, was in a sense the alter ego of the Buddha, how he would have been if he'd have been a righteous king.
And I also sort of try to put it in terms of ourselves, that there's the Buddha within us and there's us as actors in the world, and that each of us have our own domains.
in the sense of what we can do, our power.
But I wanted to then just go on to this wheel-turning monarch.
He says, after hundreds of thousands of years, the king, Dala Nemi, said to a certain man, my good man, whenever you see the sacred wheel treasure, that's the wheel-turning treasure, has slipped from its position, report it to me.
Well, he does.
And the king says, well, it's time for me to retire now.
So he tells his son that the sacred wheel treasure has slipped from its position.
And I've heard when this happens to a wheel turning monarch, he has not much longer to live.
So he does the right thing.
He said he's fed up with human pleasures.
It's time to get into heavenly pleasures.
And so off he goes, shaves his head off and beard, puts on the ochre robes and goes forth from the household life into homelessness.
then his son takes over and seven days after the royal sage had gone forth the sacred wheel treasure vanished bad news so he then is a bit worried about this he calls upon the sage and the sage said you should know that the wheel treasure has disappeared but he says do not grieve or feel sad at the disappearance the wheel treasure
is not an heirloom from your fathers, but now, my son, you must turn yourself into a noble wheel-turner.
And he gives him certain things that he has to do for this wheel to turn up.
And he says, he asks him, what is the duty?
So he says, right, so yourself, depending on the Dharma, honoring it, revering it, cherishing it, doing homage to it and venerating it,
having the Dhamma as your badge and banner, acknowledging the Dhamma as your master, you should establish righteous guard, ward and protection for your own household, your troops, your katiyas, that's his caste, and vassals, for Brahmins and householders, town and country folk, ascetics and Brahmins, for beasts and birds.
Let no crime prevail in your kingdom, and to those who are in need, give wealth,
And whatever ascetics and Brahmins in your kingdom have renounced the life of sensual infatuation and are devoted to forbearance and gentleness, each one taming himself, each one calming himself, and each one striving for the end of craving, from time to time you should approach them and ask, what venerable sir is wholesome and what is unwholesome, blameworthy and blameless?
What action will in the wrong run lead to harm and sorrow and what to welfare?
happiness so he does all this of course and blow me down the wheel appears now having the wheel having now appeared he he also has of course the seven treasures of the wheel turning monarch they are this divine wheel which it has all its spokes and all that in fact I think it yes that's right the other day
That's right.
And he says, and he did all this.
And then the sacred wheel treasure appeared to him.
Thousand spokes, complete with rim hub and all accessories.
So this is this mythical wheel, the Dharma wheel, right?
Now he does have other treasures.
His other seven treasures are the elephant.
You have a good elephant.
A horse.
And this horse is special because it can fly through the air.
He has a water-puring gem.
That tells you the importance of water in that society.
A good woman.
That's very important, isn't it?
And a treasurer who can see hidden treasure.
In other words, where you've hidden your money.
And finally, a very wise counsellor.
So with these seven treasures, he ends up being this world-turning monarch.
Now, here comes the meat of it, you see, because this Brahmin,
addresses the Blessed One and he asks him he asks him I've heard that you understand how to conduct successfully the triple sacrifice with its 16 requisites now I do not understand all this but I want to make a big sacrifice it would be good if Master Gautama would explain it to me now
These sacrifices were based on the idea of appeasing gods.
If you wanted a god to do something, you had to give him something.
Even in the Bible, God wants Abraham to kill his son.
It's this idea of giving something up to get something.
And you have power over the person or over the god.
By this time, these sacrifices weren't a case of let's try and appease the gods.
It was more, if the sacrifice was done perfectly, God had to answer.
And the thing was that it really wasn't happening very much.
And people were losing faith in that sort of, you know, the big sacrifice.
These sacrifices, like the king's sacrifice, hundreds of horses were slaughtered, and cows.
I mean, it was a big thing.
It wasn't just, you know, get the old mangyin,
sheep dog or something and sort of hanging from a tree or something and it was all done with with uh with precision and in other in other scriptures it goes into you know what was necessary for these sacrifices to be perfected but here this this brahmin has come to him and and the and the buddha tells him a story about this king called mahavijita so he was rich and of great wealth and resources abundance of gold and silver of possessions and requisites
of money and money's worth and with a full treasury and granary.
And when the king was reflecting in private and thought came to him, I have acquired extensive wealth in human terms and I occupy a wide extensive land which I have conquered.
Let me now make a great sacrifice that would be to my benefit and happiness for a long time.
And calling his chaplain, that would have been a Brahmin, he told him his thought.
I want to make a big sacrifice.
Instruct me, venerable sir,
how this may be to my lasting benefits and happiness.
So his listener, this fellow who's asked him about the sacrifice, would have expected him to go into some sort of detail on how to make these big sacrifices.
But the Buddha says to him, but this chaplain replied, your majesty's country is beset by thieves.
It is ravaged.
Villages and towns are being destroyed.
The countryside is infested with brigands.
In other words, he's telling us what the country was like when the country he's actually in, now living, the Buddha.
There were brigands and thieves and everything else.
And if your majesty were to tax this reason, that would be a wrong thing to do.
Suppose your majesty were to think, I will get rid of this plague of robbers by execution as an imprisonment or by confiscation, threats and banishment.
The plague would not be properly ended.
Ah, it's interesting, isn't it?
See?
to all these politicians that want to punish these people, put them in jail for hundreds of thousands of years, to those in the kingdom who are engaged in cultivation, sorry, I've lost it, banishment, right, those who survived would later harm your majesty's realm.
However, with this plan, you can completely eliminate the plague.
To those in the kingdom who are engaged in cultivating crops and raising cattle,
Let your majesty distribute grain and fodder.
To those in trade, give capital.
To those in government service, assign proper wages.
Then those people, being intent in their own occupations, will not harm the kingdom.
Your majesty's revenues will be great.
The land will be tranquil and not beset by thieves.
And the people will join their hearts, playing with their children, will dwell in open houses.
Idyllic, isn't it?
And saying so be it, the king accepted the chaplain's advice.
He gave grain and so on.
And those people, intent on being their own occupations, did not harm the kingdom.
The king's revenue became great.
The land was tranquil and not beset by thieves.
And the people, with joy in their hearts, playing with their children, dwell in open houses.
So this is the Buddha's form of government.
And just as...
just something to reflect upon that he now often you get Buddhism criticized for not being active not being proactive and not being engaged I think that's beginning to fade now because there's a lot of engaged Buddhism but the Buddha had his own ideas of you know how people ought to be ruled and he's two very good friends
were the local kings Bimbisara down in Benares modern day Benares and Pasanadi up in the north now he would have known these people I think from childhood they were his age group and during his time there was no war between them it was a very peaceful period it all began to break up as he was dying the sons began to well
Bimbisara's son went and murdered his father he starved him to death kicked him off the throne but the other form of government which we'll come to later on was this more tribal based custom where it was more like an aristocracy a bit like the Greeks so the Buddha's father would have been the head man of
that group of people of that tribe called the Sakyas who would be elected now in this book Bhikkhu Bodhi says that the Buddha doesn't he seems to be even handed with both types of government but the government he left for the order was of the community type he didn't leave a Pope he didn't leave somebody in charge at all and he said you know you've got to be a
take the Dharma as your refuge and yourself as your refuge so the government that he wanted for the order was the government of elders I think that's where his heart was and probably because that's the way he was brought up but at least here we see in these sorts of discourses that the Buddha was trying to in many ways when he was talking to people people in power, Brahmins and stuff to
expressed the Dharma as something which was guiding the society, guiding not only individual behavior, but social behavior, monarchical behavior, the behavior of governments, you see.
And you've only got to consider, you know, if everybody in the world just now said they wouldn't kill any other human being, even that would be a tremendous change, wouldn't it?
Or stop thieving people.
Especially copper.
I saw the headlines of copper.
Brilliant, isn't it?
So these are just things to ponder.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance.
May you be liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.